hello and welcome to this video and
western okay what is he going to do d
for Bishop f4 that's not very exciting
actually the plate c5 not as a pre move
but close to that okay so d5 hmm I got
Queen to be six hours from very likely
playing Knight c3 for some gamma bird
okay maybe just a benoni uh-huh okay
that's sorry about that but I should
drink before the video starts oh my god
I'm sorry ah ok its own and there is
Knight takes e4 in this position Queen
takes we should be true but there's hmm
but he's got it should be fine but I
can't threaten that on Knight f3 I'm
threatening this ok I go Bishop g4 is
going 92 so that's no good let's go here
yeah it's a fairly normal position for a
decline Vanko it's just that the bishop
is on a form which is a little bit
unusual but it doesn't feel like a a bad
place for this piece
92 95 95 is a move or just take I can
take and go night be 64 simple chest mm
I thought night takes d5 as possible but
he's got night txt five against that hmm
okay
hmm i can go Rukia to prepare that maybe
I don't really see anything great now
for him yeah well I got a key right why
is that impossible night b7 I actually
have night before and don't quite
understand I think it should be possible
um maybe 95 Queen a five before takes it
tonight c7 something like that but then
Roxy 8 is coming okay yeah this is a
little bit of a tricky spots here
because my I'm not a developed well
another night on be eight okay so i have
to God c7 something like before I could
be interesting okay um Bishop a five and
lightsey Sam they are both them both
them in this position okay
the good thing is I'm a pawn up so I can
um possibly just return stuff okay
cannot go queen to d7 rupee eight maybe
also getting out of that night c74 also
threatening night XD five now so going
to c8 take that that's possible
yeah my eggs just keep everything nice
27 and don't see any issue this is
intact this isn't technically all that
easy but still have to get rid of the
night or let him take their can also go
here first
oh I know how stupid can you be ok it's
not that big a deal that completely
unnecessary makes it more difficult now
there are no tactics or anything five
and King up to you six something like
that and then try to mop things up on
the queenside maybe have six instead of
f5 for more stability I'd like to get in
hoops the agency form let's do this and
king of seven and rook c8 yahoo
what's good here technically speaking
this is still a peer time morning so
tick ticking there doesn't really do
much can take with the rook not sure
what's best technically didn't expect
that move
check check yeah there isn't all that
great check my porn is very much behind
check check aha no shoot that was set
was great check check check white
forfeits on time Jim what can you do I
just blundered that bloody porn but yeah
a little bit of a shame I think it was a
decently played game up to one point
okay so um bit of a real opening there
he surprised me a bit was c4 i was
thinking more like lights III go for a
quick come peace development not sure
about this banker which it should it
should be possible I mean it's like a
normal banker with the dish ammonia form
here's interesting moment I think after
this I can take here there's a tactic
that I recently saw yeah winning this so
has to be careful there I couldn't do it
right here because there is Bishop b5
and now this this feels somewhat normal
yeah so now I decided to take this yeah
here before this is move i mentioned
that is probably interesting if i take
it i was thinking this but then we'll
see aid works the computer however
points our jackets which is pretty cool
check this the idea so hmm check okay I
can do this but then you will take you
for a good position probably I have to
go back out what I did here is certainly
very risky you have my development isn't
good yeah that was the way to punish it
here I'm getting away and have basically
just a pawn up position without any
issues take stakes and now a e5 is
stupid i just have to the idea is not
bad strategically but I just have to
prevent oops bishop not this one in
Bishop to c7 it makes it a little bit
more difficult but ok it's still very
nice so you know TX takes pawn takes
rook c3 of course yeah it's just a
double attack missing is the simple idea
okay that would have won the way it the
way it was played out oops I didn't see
looks it to hear that was winning of
course check check
okay that was very simple yeah bad end
game but then can play chat chat yeah
this is unfortunately China thing and
probably I should should have gone to g6
and try it yeah now you're cute you just
cannot play for winners I mean I tried
stuff but blood and blundered in the
process ya hear things it is it is an
equal position with to the channel it's
a bit easier for him to play oops with
the pawns yes and how I should take with
the awkward raw but ok it was a dream
just chat at the end I'm even losing but
ok time time is playing as well yeah
tough fighting game ok thanks for
watching